[Music]
you know coming back to chicago this was
a no-brainer uh for us i absolutely love
this town and i love the food in chicago
you guys have the best food in the world
but you know
this time around
this time around i promised myself i
would try and eat healthy and so far
i've been pretty good here's what i've
had to eat in the last couple days
saturday i started off with an egg white
omelet
for lunch i had a caesar salad at gino's
east
for dinner i had two bacon double
cheeseburgers at ed de bevex for dessert
i had two more bacon double
cheeseburgers
now sunday i started with another egg
white omelet which was served on top of
a deep dish pizza with extra sausage
from lou malnati's i watched that down
watch that down with a six-pack old
style and a grilled cheese from the
billy goat
slept through lunch okay
then had a light dinner of two italian
beef sandwiches at al's
and a midnight snack of flaming saganaki
from greek islands
and then today i just stayed in my hotel
room and ate nothing but 20 toblerone
chocolate bars
along with an eight-piece meal of
harold's fried chicken
now
fantastic
now finally
this is all leading somewhere earlier
today i got my cholesterol checked
i understand the numbers are in right
now let's go live at this moment this is
a live feed now to dr
dom swarsky he's the head
cardiologist
head cardiologist at rush
university medical center i hope this
feeds intact hello there doctor can you
hear me hey hey there collins welcome to
chicago all right now now so
doc just give it to me straight all
right okay let me check it out here
you're gonna die all right
thank you
thank you doctor that's a relief it's
good to find out
just get him out of here
yeah all right he's uh he'll be fine